herzlich kommt zu einer neuen folge ich
teste leute ich bin heute in rüsselsheim
und heute gibt es wieder eine premiere
für euch heute gibt es den ersten bmw
und zeitgleich das erste getunte auto
bei ich teste wir verhalten zuschauer
auto und zwar ein z4 m 40
dass der wagen von jan
[Musik]
wow wow erst mal harte fakten vorneweg
z4 m 40 hat eigentlich 340 ps sehr genau
wer aber nicht nee der ja hat jetzt 480
ps
anstatt 50 meter haben wir 640
newtonmeter alles auf die hinterachse
reaktion dass ab und zu da ab und zu
auch nicht da aber es macht einfach nur
super viel spaß lassen warum schauen
hier also komm mal hier steht sehr gut
da roadster also ist mit stoffdach das
kann man reinmachen genau wer also ich
bin ein an sich muss ich sagen feiere
ich eigentlich hardtop mehr als
stoffdach aber wenn es unten ist es
sowieso egal
guck mal hier war sehr schön das finde
ich bei bmw sowieso immer geil ich bin
auch kein bmw etr muss ich sagen wir
viele leute die keine ahnung mercedes
fahrende audi fahren die hätten bmw
ich find behrendt egal ob motoren kommen
wir gleich drauf und hören wir auch
gleich noch das hektiker was ich habe
ist ich hab jetzt noch nicht geschaut
fake blende nach gras okay er gut war
sie bis hin vergrößert sondern eher
haben sie dann daraus genau also von der
form her nicht aber ist alles ist alles
echt und ich und schwingt auch ne genau
ist alles echt schwingt auch geil der
herzog von gaddafi werfen einen blick
rein da muss ich sagen leute da bin ich
sehr sehr positiv überrascht es probleme
mit bmw mann hatte war dass der
innenraum einfach früher sehr sehr es
aussah mittlerweile hier aber schon
deutlich bessere materialien der
fensterheber der sieht noch so ein
bisschen aus wie früher
ja aber hat andere hat andere qualitäten
anderen können wir wollen jetzt auch
nicht dass ein paarmal kardon anlage
hast du hier sieht schon sieht schon
frisch aus keine hintere sitzreihe dafür
hier die lautsprecher genau niemand ganz
genau sind glaube ich zwölf an der zahl
klar beim roadster ist halt alles ein
bisschen kompakter ist wieder
komprimierter das heißt es fühlt sich so
schön weil du hast halt direkt im nacken
genau das heißt direkt im nacken und
kriegst also von hinten von vorne von
oben von unten bisher auch nicht
zugedröhnt ist alles erst mal von
staufach für videochats die kanzlerin
machen nächster technik durch die
durchreiche technik genau die geht
einmal nach innen durch das heißt du
kannst auch mal was da drin
transportieren das funktioniert aber
ansonsten passt eigentlich alles geil
und wichtig leute für die praxis wert
wirklich ein ja ordentlichen kofferraum
der ist nicht witzig da geht schon was
rein manchmal wissen wann soundcheck
machen ich bin sehr gespannt klar gerne
sehr sehr geil
ok
[Musik]
geil geil geil geil schön abgase 1
machen müssen was gibt es besseres im
leben leute das ist wirklich einfach
highlight das können wir auch dazu sagen
der motor drin ist der b58 sehr bekannt
dass auch der im 440 ihn genau ist wird
wird er seit längerem gebaut sind 440
war auch in 435 im 135
ganz viele verschiedene bmw modell und
ist jetzt in so einer mittleren
ausbaustufe ist der jetzt bei serie 380
ps gewesen ja ich glaube die aktuelle
ausbaustufe hat 374 ps
aber sie ist halt viele sehr ich glaube
er ist relativ robust und also hier was
haben wir drin ich habe gesagt der wagen
diskussion du hast eine software
leistungssteigerung genau und eine
downpipe gehen und insgesamt einfach mal
140 ps extra rausgefahren jetzt die
erste frage ist natürlich immer was
bedeuten autos für dich diese losung
foto frage er seien sich das mal ein
vater eben bei einem mit dem auto wie
konzern gearbeitet wo er arbeitet ja da
1 autos für uns schon immer ja was heißt
alltäglich also relativ offen neuer
dienstwagen damals konnte noch
schönemann konfigurieren das heißt
kannst du dich ausruhen verhandelt so
bin ich halt auch irgendwie ein bisschen
diese sparte reingerutscht ja immer zu
sehen ob alle vier fünf monate standort
neu ist und der kleine jan hat dann mal
geguckt okay was können wir denn haben
was können wir den nicht haben er hat
papa so lange genervt sein gesehen hat
gut wir machen das man übergangsweise es
hat mich dahin so ein bisschen an
gepusht und an sich generell die
leidenschaften ja also du hast ja eine
gute wahl getroffen wie gesagt der motor
an sich hat richtig viel potenzial
richtig krass tun das kann natürlich
schon ein potenzial ich glaube allein
die stage 1 also ist es heute viele von
euch wissen manche nicht ist einfach
dass man eine andere software quasi auf
spielt auf das auf das motorsteuergerät
und dadurch kannst du einfach mit ja
quasi einer datei verschieben
denn das auto deutlich leistungsstärker
machen und der geht schon sehr sehr weit
hoch nur mit der software denn auch ja
also ich glaube
der erste schritt allein mit software
kommt man auf um die 420 ps bis 180 ps
und stahl und generell auch die serie
motoren so wie ich das auch mitbekommen
habe schon rollen schon sehr bald da
oben ja gar schon ein sehr sehr guter
motor sehr ausbaufähiger motor und hat
steckt hat super viel potenzial drin
wir haben halt und dann klar wenn du
dann stage 23 also wenn man turbo lader
geht wenn man andauernd 1 auspuffanlage
erstmal einfach noch ein bisschen
aufbaut dann stehen da auch mal 55 600
ps ist schon geil geil geil und wir sind
wir relativ leicht unterwegs
manche würden sagen für rosa schwer aber
1,6 tonnen sind für die leistung
wirklich nicht viel
das ist bin ich sehr gespannt wie das
geht wenn ich jetzt gleich am start das
erste mal hier drücke hecktriebler also
ein bisschen vorsicht ist geboten
meinst du gerade ihm schon aber das
kriegen wir auf jeden fall richtig halte
auch ich habe nicht so ein bisschen so
bisschen so ein bmw auf verguckt
vielleicht ein audi kind aber ich bin
sehr sehr jetzt sehr gespannt auf den
den ersten bmw in diesem format der
wagen an sich auch eine geile weiß
exotisch irgendwann schon mal so gesagt
und schon hat man nicht oft in der in
sieht man die offene der kombi z4 und
sieht man schon öfter mal genauer
verschlechterten generation so ältere
als 20 ihrer was ich alles so den m40
ideen gibt es ja auch erst seit zwei
jahren oder so und man kann gut man kann
nun sind also ich bemerke vom
beifahrersitz aus hier so ja da ist von
m im namen aber das ist jetzt keine bret
harte schleuder hier also man kann gut
kochen halten diesen roadster der kann
auch noch jetzt stand hier das wir nicht
reinlassen in der inhalt leder dann ist
es okay wie cruisen so entspannt der
fühlt sich auch nicht riesig groß an
also also keine sitze hier in kompakten
roadster ist er wahrscheinlich wieder
große ganze ganz anderen review haben
gesagt ja das schon
wirklich sehr massiv an aber ich finde
sich kompakter im vergleich zu dem was
man sonst so viel habe er klar also ich
meine mit sicherheit ist ein tt und
einen boxter die jetzt irgendwo dieser
range spielen hier ticken kleiner von
den abmessungen her aber auch einfach
auf gut deutsch ist diese riesige langen
schnauze nach vorne hast mit dem großen
motor auf jeden fall immer lieber eine
lange schnauze als vierzylinder
sechszylinder ist einfach geil muss ich
sagen also jungs und mädels da draußen
solange wir noch können müssen wir
möglichst viele zylinder fahren dass er
weiß wie lange das noch geht er meint zu
wissen ja man steuern lassen
hätte ich auch gesagt du gucken wir dass
wir da vorne man spot finden wir ja was
eine standen lüftung ja klar wenn ich
aussteige sagt mir das auto auf die
standorte von anmachen geworden ist
flex dann hätte er den wagen könne ja
leute selbst 44 stage 2 plus so sagt er
ps du hast ps machen lassen genau mps
engineering war jetzt mal her okay okay
alles klar oder linke okay
ja
[Musik]
sehr geil
das ist ein geiler geiler typ tiger test
den wir hier ja ok seither ist eine sehr
breite reifen von er gefühlt hat man hat
so ein schwimmgefühl das hatte ich auch
glaubt dass mit federn fahrwerk oder
vielleicht auf den größeren reifen die
etwas niedrigere und quer stellt haben
ja das ist einfach noch ein bisschen
direkt da ist ja das können wir auch 2k
des autos nicht ausgelegt auf diese
leistung kann man so sagen
der heckantrieb funktioniert mit der
serienleistung wunderbare du hast auch
nie das gefühl dass das auto dich
irgendwie übermannt und wird keine
kontrolle hast aber tatsächlich man kann
denn jetzt auch sehr gestellt haben ja
und wenn du spaß dann kriegst du spaß
schön
[Musik]
geil geil geil geil aber die idee ist
auch sehr sehr sehr face und englisches
wort denn so response also ja ich dachte
so single turbo s hat nur einen
turbolader der motor leute dachte er hat
vielleicht ein turboloch von der so aber
ist sofort da und er knallt aber auf
ordentliche entschluss das glaubt man
tatsächlich erst dann wirklich proben
sehr sehr oberen drehzahlbereich also
der gang wird nicht ausschließt kann man
muss manuell dann kann man ganz einfach
schalten jetzt also wenn ich alt ist
dann geht auf manuel neuer geht da
stehst du vorne unten genau 1 3 und
jetzt bleibt noch die ganzen
[Musik]
aha
es ist leider nicht so solange aber
wirklich sind wenn du die gänge er dann
im dritten viertel machte das schon
der allerdings hatte auch er wehrt sich
auch was meinst du schon rein
programmiert wenn du davon hast dann
kommt sofort den hörer also die daumen
erzählt eingebaut
das heißt es oft wie gesagt mit tüv dann
die software steigerungen gemacht und
die leistungssteigerung per software
freund auch dort habe ich die
möglichkeit hat noch mal zu sagen okay
inwieweit können wir das denn extremer
gestalten oder eben nicht extrem ihr
habt schon standardmäßig ein bisschen
nach japan
[Musik]
das einfach lauter und ein bisschen
länger zu halten anstatt dass es so
super aufdringlich ist weil es ja doch
in ihren roadster ist und wie finde ich
eine kasse nicht so eine akronyme genau
man fußt ja doch eher
[Musik]
sehr geil ich habe den regio dazu
gesehen zu dem auto gemeint einer dass
der bmw typisch so eine weißwurst dickes
lenkrad ja aber das ist auch schon es
ist ja es ist präsenter ist präsent aber
ich finde immer noch ist nicht retten
guten auf jeden fall auch dann
vielleicht überlegen bisschen was mit
ein paar tage zu machen dass man mittels
und paar kleine details noch mal an sich
im innenraum was willst du was hätte ich
machen ohne extrem jetzt arbeiten
durchführen zu lassen heutzutage ja
lenkradschaltung ja es ist alles ist mir
noch ist nicht mehr mit wandler
reinpumpen ja genau und hat alles rund
[Musik]
ok
jawoll junge via la garza ps ist dahin
eher aktive das auto da hat die
traktionskontrolle gearbeitet wird egal
das ist ja richtig geil wenn ihr einen
kicker und gips sondern die reifen
drehen ein bisschen durchs haben war ich
bin so allrad verwöhnt ich kann das gar
nicht nicht optimale traktion aber das
leben ist ja auch kein quartett wenn wir
darum wie sich sand fühlt und ihren auch
der die krasseste zeit hat am ende und
bremsen sind sehr sehr gut dosierbar
finde ich diese nicht zu hart sind schön
angenehm dass bei weißem licht rein
dieser des ok man fühlt sich sehr sehr
flach sehr flach also bei flaches auto
breitreifen ist es so wenn noch so auf
der straße landstraße
[Musik]
na ja ein bisschen locker hinten auf man
merkt doch manchmal dass er raus regel
wahlweise kommt jetzt für ihn zu weit
quer hören die vollen 650 newtonmeter
abzurufen
das leben hat er so wissen sie sagt er
dann
[Musik]
hambergen aufschlag
schlagen aber die sache ist außer ich
fand ich fahre jetzt so und ich denke
mir ich will ich will denen sowieso hin
überfordern ich will dass der
subtraktion verstöße zu hart um die
kurven wie dürften oder so aber das ist
vielleicht aus und wir beten dass so ein
hecktriebler versuchen wir das denn die
linke akl es manchmal schwer ist aber
und er ist auch niro also der hat so
auch so verrückt das element aber der
ist nie so provision gt-r sowieso alles
arbeitet und du hast alles klackern und
pfeifen ist immer immer ein raffiniert
das auto also im sinne von ausgefeiltes
auto das einzige was ich mir denke ist
wenn er so bis achteinhalb drehen würde
das geht so losgeht so was kommen wird
doch nicht bei sechseinhalb aufhören so
will es jetzt mal leute das geht gut
bergauf aber mal gucken bisschen rein
punkten
wo ich bin
kitzbühel
friedberg auf 4,69 bin ich finde ich auf
jeden fall okay es war also gut
durchgedreht am anfang und gutes stück
bergauf nur leute zweiter versuch
wie gesagt zwei man hier drin tankred
die feuerwehr jetzt yalla gut angefühlt
er hat sich viel schneller angefühlt
hallo 4,18 blitz-ko hauskauf danke dir
wird die gelegenheit problem und wir
kommerz zu bewerten und die beginnt wie
immer aus dem z4 ist definitiv ein
schönes auto aber weil ihm so dass eine
herausstehende element das besondere
design element fehlt auch wenn er sehr
schön dass herr kapriziert weniger als
die acht von zehn punkte der gt-r
bekommen hat unter 911 gts von g-power
deswegen 7 von 10 punkten die
beschleunigung ist amtlich 4 sekunden
von null auf hundert mit der
leistungssteigerung das reicht für acht
von zehn punkten ein cooles auto ist
jetzt viel definitiv auch aber auch hier
fehlt mir so das gewisse etwas was wir
einen der drei höchsten werte reichen
würde deswegen auch hier sieben von zehn
die praktikabilität ist für den roadster
ziemlich gut aber natürlich über die
breite alle autos hinweg gesehen nicht
so wirklich top mann hat zwar eine
durchreiche und relativ großen
kofferraum aber eben keine rücksitzen
deswegen gibt es hier vier von zehn das
preis leistungsverhältnis gegen ist
wirklich top der wagen kostet sowie
janin gebrauch geholt hat circa 50.000
euro dann noch mal ein paar tausend für
die leistungssteigerung oben drauf da
bekommt man wirklich ein top auto von
einem luxus hersteller für ein sehr sehr
gutes geld sieben von zehn in den
komfort schlussendlich sehe ich auf
einem niveau mit den neuen eltern auf
dem nissan gt-r man hat hier sportliche
autos die aber auch sehr gut im alltag
bewegt werden könnte man merkt in ihre
sportlichkeit aber trotzdem an die sind
nicht ganz komfortabel und das wollen
sie auch nicht sein trotzdem müssen wir
in puncto komfort mit den bisherigen
komfort liedern der e klasse und dem gt3
und 60s vergleichen und deswegen ist
hier 5 von 10 punkten damit komplize
vier am ende auf 38 von 60 punkten eben
weil er doch an eher sportliches auto
ist keine wirkliche allzweckwaffe die
sehr komfortabel oder auch noch sehr
praktisch dabei das 68 das heißt platz
acht von elf der bisher getesteten autos
in der gesamtwertung arbeitsgang leute
und zwar habe ich eine getrennte wertung
für die drei faktoren aus dem coolen
sondern auch eine kombinierte wertung
für die drei alltags faktoren
praktikabilität preis leistung komfort
eingeführt in der sparte komplett 4 mit
22 von 30 punkten auf einen geteilten
sechsten platz zusammen mit dem e 63 amg
cabrio und dem bmw i8 in alltags wertung
jetzt mit 16 von 30 punkten einen
geteilten siebten platz zusammen mit dem
911 gts von g-power unterstreicht
definitiv ein topauto gratuliere dir zu
deiner wahl und wir sehen uns nächsten
sonntag leute bis dann